let's jump into the story about the
coronavirus so check this out so I can
freak you all out a whole lot more we
have the story from I guess it's live
science live live science live science
how long can the new coronavirus last on
surfaces nine days nine days this is
this so this is actually week old
information but I'm bringing it up first
because we're not gonna talk about the
severity of everything and I know yeah a
lot of people may have already been up
to date may have been watching some my
other videos talking about coronavirus
we're gonna talk a bit about it but I
want to make sure I just show you some
of the latest details this is from today
or it's updated to it was from yesterday
updated today the CDC has said it's not
a question of if but when look at she
looks worried if you ask me I mean it's
already here it's here yeah it's already
here so for the people that have it
they've contacted people before they
knew that they have nine days on a
surface nine days on the surface and a
24 day incubation period up to 27 up to
27 so here's where I should period so
like who knows so here's we're gonna do
I'm we're gonna go through some of these
very important details for all of you
because this isn't this is important
Adam I don't think you've seen this
story I want you to read this let's say
dozens of passengers who are allowed off
the Diamond Princess cruise after
testing negative for coronavirus are now
showing symptoms Wow 45 people so the
testing that they were doing it doesn't
even work or or they caught it after 14
days so so they were quarantined for 14
days and then they said you guys are all
good no symptoms no tests yeah now
they're sick that's crazy
it's coming so it's it's happening it's
coming so Trump is apparently appointing
Mike Pence in charge of the corona virus
response so you have experience with
tackle ins comes um I don't know they
don't on this question I have no idea
but I will tell you I will tell you
let's just like so those are the big key
updates but let's just just jump into
the general conversation yeah okay I'm
sick of the politicking yeah that's true
dude I am forget it
I am so here's the thing I'm frustrated
with Trump mmm but I do I do have to be
a little bit fair he's been saying like
it's gonna be fine
calm down don't worry about it I built a
wall it'll be over in a few months
yeah people are okay with it now I can
understand why they would have to do
that right yeah like if they come out
and they're like the end is near go now
like people are gonna freak out start
smashing windows and dead sure I
understand that the need to keep people
calm because the last thing you want is
for people to panic so what you want to
do is promote promote the idea of the
severity without panicking people right
but I don't think he's doing that enough
he said no no no and I think his concern
is the markets taking a hit yeah but
then you get some of the people on the
other side I'm not gonna say that he
they who shall not be named and they're
like it's the government's fault and I'm
like woah woah woah dude dude dude we do
not need you politicking right now we
have a serious crisis an emergency
I sure we can throw some criticism you
know towards the president right but
let's all sit back on the pilot fly the
plane and and and not try and disrupt
this stuff right it's getting it's it's
really annoying to me when I when I wake
up in the morning and I'm like what's
the news and they're like they're
turning the the coronavirus into a
political debate that's ridiculous
because how we're gonna deal with it
it's not political it's it's an actual
virus that's hitting humans all
coronavirus isn't political what they're
making has has has Trump gone after the
Democrats accusing them of doing
anything Ron's
haven't seen it yeah no he's been he's
been look for better for worse doing
what he needs to be doing I guess but I
don't know if you saw the the videos
Adam I haven't seen anything no I've
been just listen yourself man you're out
gallivanting about climbing walls
standing doing get making you know or
you know flexing and taking your
Prentice patient trophies while the
world's burning down all around you man
yeah so no that's actually really good
point cutting through my coffee
everything's fine in Italy oh there's
videos you do know a little bit about
those yeah so in Italy there's that the
quarantine is really bad and there are
people fighting in the streets I didn't
know about this in the shops over stuff
so I don't know exactly what the fights
are over but there's a video of like two
guy walks up and just clock
another guy in the face and really just
yeah they're not fighting over a product
just goes I don't know walks I don't
know exactly all I know is gave me crude
no no the shelves are just ripped oh
there's nothing there the funny thing is
they left the pasta I'm not kidding
well everyone probably already has the
box at home that I would you know what I
was gonna I was gonna ask why that was
and you just gave me the answer I think
of the point like I were good so we went
to we went to Sam's Club oh yeah
and there was like nobody in there got
some ice cream that's surprising every
time I've ever been in Sam's Club is
packed
so here's yeah packed here's here's the
thing like I thought when the CDC
announced you need to go now cuz yeah I
got I got I I know if you guys been
watching my stuff you probably see me
talk about this but this freaked me out
it's genuinely freaked me out yeah first
this girl looks worried here this is
like the doctor Nancy messy in there
mess miss Yuna non-apparent Snape I'm
messy no miss Anya Missoni a Sonya oh I
don't know maybe maybe it's French yeah
cool she looks kind of worried but
apparently she warned people over a
media call okay here's the thing though
apparently she was telling okay what are
you doing Daily Mail don't show Matt's
gross that apparently she's talking
about how she was telling her kids like
her family it's gonna get really bad and
you need to prepare for a severe
disruption in your lives
we're gonna shut down and so I'm
thinking is if she's gonna admit this to
the media yeah and normally the CDC is
like no you know and and she's telling
her family yeah yeah I think it's
actually worse than she's letting on I
think it's way worse so what happened
with Italy was they had a few isolated
cases now they're the worst affected
country outside of Asia oh wow yep and
that night I heard South Korea's hit
really bad also yeah you know about that
right Lydia I don't know if it's worse
than Italy but I heard it yeah I thought
that was the second-worst
Italy went from like 14 to 58 over the
course of like 24 hours oh whoa yeah so
it jumped exponentially I think that was
probably the biggest deal so I don't
know if the actual number is comparable
to somewhere like China okay but the
sheer increase in cases was just like
shocking
there's a mess you got nine days on
surfaces
you've got 14 potentially in some
circumstances 27 day incubation
transmission while asymptomatic airborne
this is like worst case scenario
my shields - yeah I mean weeks ago it
was like okay it might hit 60% of the
population and that was like a light
gasp that was them being like worst-case
scenarios we're looking at 60% global it
feels like it's gonna hit like 80 90 %
no I don't know man
no no you know it's weird everyone knows
every what is a six degrees of
separation yeah right so it's the same
kind of thing here you know you go meet
your you're friendly with with the with
the incubation period yeah exam with
asymptomatic transmission yes exactly
it's like everyone's gonna get everyone
I mean it's like we're in plague inc
Greenland's the only safe spot I mean of
course it's funny that we all do live in
our own little bubbles though so it is
kind of you know some there's gonna be a
lot of people that are totally
unaffected by that side thing so here's
the thing this is what really bothers me
cuz I'm sitting here like hearing us I'm
thinking about what we're talking about
and I'm like is really really poor like
we're gonna end you know like I know how
we I would have bought a bunch of water
yeah we got a bunch of 5-gallon things
of water we got some rice and beans and
flour cuz like you know like I said this
on Twitter the worst-case scenario is
guess what you have taco night for a
week here at Joe's that you have seven
days a taco night in one month it's not
the worst thing ever I love taco night
if it only was actually had taco night
earlier is great with we had chicken in
a slow cooker with some cheese I'm
looking forward to it actually but if
you don't go out and get anything and
this turns out to be really bad until
all the chickens die
yeah I mean well the coronavirus is
gonna kill him what we're talking about
humans being affected by this aren't
animals gonna be hit by this too are
they now I don't think so they not can't
can't like I mean this one with all the
problems in it I mean chickens don't get
on planes well it doesn't matter the
farmer might the farmers gonna know his
son that but it's not gonna do shock
from not gonna jump from the human of
the animal if it's airborne saying that
goes through your eyelids so I'm just
asking can't can an animal get it they
can't get us we got it from them and as
far as I understand
not be transmitted rare mutation wrath
yeah okay so so here's what here's what
here's I want to say I want to say you
know they've been saying the whole time
chill out
yeah and then it's gotten worse every
step of the way yeah China was like dude
in January it was what 14 people for
real like beginning January was like 14
people have a strange new respiratory
illness and now it's like 80,000 people
and 3,000 dead it's like it's been two
months yeah that's crazy is it really
that bad I don't know but what I can say
is governments are freaking out and the
way I always see I always you know think
about it is I think their actions speak
so much louder than their words if if
the government's like everything's gonna
be cool but then and then they plan to
the CDs like telling your family like
you guys need to prep it's gonna get bad
make sure cuz everything's gonna hit the
fan finds me of like a disaster movie
exactly yeah tomorrow where the dude
called his kid and he's like it's gonna
get bad stateside no one else knew
actually yes a really good example yeah
you guys have seen Day After Tomorrow
right you're right Jake Gyllenhaal it's
a phone call from his dad who says stay
inside the storm is going to freeze
everybody and so he goes in the library
and then all the people leave except for
like 6 people and he's like don't leave
don't leave and they're like oh please
and then all dead yeah that's what it
feels like so she's like telling her
family that she gets the phone with
these reporters and they're still this
is the craziest thing I see these people
from like I don't want to name the
outlet mm-hmm
lefty digital outlets being like these
stories about China longing in the in
the bio lab it's just propaganda to make
China look bad because the Conservatives
hate China or whatever and I'm like okay
man you should go you should go over
there and interview them yeah I'm joking
dude but here's the crazy thing too when
when I tweeted something about when this
really if this does become what they're
calling disease X that's what the World
Health Organization is scared it's the
hypothetical disease that meat which is
like global penetration yeah I was like
people are gonna be sure glad that
Donald Trump built that wall yeah I've
built the wall and people on Twitter are
like you're so dumb of folks can't stop
a virus
no do you know who carries the viruses
like there's not like little germs
floating through the air like going
there's a
all yeah right now I'm like it's a human
being coughing yeah and then stopping at
the fence and going like darn turning
around I can't go this way anymore so
here's actually one I actually want to
show all of you guys something now look
I there's a little picture of me you can
see isn't that isn't that cute it's an
old picture well I got a different
colored shirt it's actually a colored
sure it's blue he's wearing a colored
shirt blue shirt so this is a website
from it's it's prepare with Tim calm I
normally I've only ever done a promo for
these guys one time and it was during I
think like a hurricane or something so I
don't like doing these Peyer gold people
didn't is near you know I I hate that
yeah I hate doing these things where
like you're you're doing an emergency
food supply mm-hmm because you've got
the bad news it feels such like now
feels well you know I did we had some
yeah and we have not even need it okay
so here's the thing I'm not I'm not
pulling this up to do a promo by no
means but I will
as an aside just to mention you know
prepare with tim calm is the site that
has it but I'm doing this to show you
this so I did a promo for this on my
earlier on my Tim cast news channel
because and I mean this sincerely all
right you've probably never seen me do
anything like this but I've done like 10
videos where I'm seriously like dude
coronavirus is getting bad you need to
take care of yourself get some water
because we've got videos of people
fighting and fighting in these shops
store shelves being drained and I'm
showing this now not as a promo but I'm
showing it because their demand is up
100 times and now they're out of time
and but but here's the thing when we
pulled this up we look at this the
update just went up five week delay and
and and literally 20 minutes ago before
we started we pulled this up house
showing Adam like hey check out this
thing four week delay Wow and since then
since we've been talking it's up to a
five week delay well earlier in the day
it was only 35 times yep when I did when
I did a promo it was 35 times so I want
a volume you man yeah yeah Wow 35 times
normal volume so here's the thing it's
not just the preppers anymore well I
think you're not it's the new the New
Age Preppers if you're not taking care
of this stuff I think you're nuts and if
you got someone from BuzzFeed
we're not if we go to her or you know
yeah like what what's the what's the
hurt of going to make sure you have like
a week's worth of water so you can you
gotta rest we need water what's you're
more concerned about your social
appearance than your survival I don't
dig my you're just preparing to take
care of your family I don't yeah well I
think the stigma comes from the people
that like build underground bunkers
security but not even that's cool no I I
do I think but I think that's where it
comes from because some of those people
are a little cuckoo there no it's
because the TV finds the cuckoo ones
you're right that's it that's where the
stigma comes from dude from the cuckoo
once think about what would happen to
you if you live in a city if you
listening at home you live in New York
City that scares me I weep for you I
lived in New York or for a long time and
I can imagine going to the store
remember sandy it was all yeah I was I
was in New York for sandy actually and
that was and the stores were all shut
down well it wasn't as bad as I thought
it would be but I was in a high ground
area in Brooklyn so I was it wasn't as
bad and we didn't lose power so it was
like but I had friends that we were
living in south south Manhattan and they
they couldn't do anything they were
stuck you know they didn't have anything
in the south it was that it's like the
Lower East Side of Manhattan yeah I
remember because I was staying in
Brooklyn and I rode my bike across the
bridge came down there was no
electricity and there were lines out the
door of there called bodegas in New York
those that are familiar yeah yeah there
are like little corner store shops that
sell that's where most people get their
milk and their bread and their eggs in
their food
you don't go to I mean there's some
grocery stores that are bigger and
better they're sporadic yeah but most
people go to the bodega and there was
there were lines at the door and they
had two guards standing at the door with
like big dudes arms crossed and they
were letting in one person at a time
they had no electricity so they couldn't
do anything other than cash transactions
okay and all of the perishables were
gone like the milk the bags and
everything they were like nah but
there's canned beans
yeah and so I went in there to see what
they had and they were like we have the
refrigerator still have soda and
everything it's all warm milk bread
cheese you can't it's gone yeah and they
were without power for like I think two
weeks some ridiculous number no you what
the cool thing about that was though
that the flooding from the hurricane
knocked over a bunch of bus stops and
skaters were riding through the streets
grinding on
oh yeah I remember seeing I was like
dude that's gonna cool like I know
you're everyone's life is kind of
miserable over this but hey you know
they can they can skateboard on the
knocked-over bus stop but it's like
bottom line is it's okay to prepare
yourself for some of this dude actually
this is this is serious coronavirus is
gonna spread to the states but here's
here's eventually it's no no it's here
it's here no so they spread it's gonna
spread around right alright so that I
think this from the CDC they said what
we think what we've tracked already in
the you know here in the u.s. yeah
there's probably already thousands of
people are you pressing the bun oh okay
I'm like we're gonna read it no so
they're saying when our case is reported
it's because we got a severe severe case
yeah somebody goes to the hospital
they're coughing they're gagging the
reason they say we're no test
that's coronavirus that means there are
tons of people who have it yep that are
probably just like it's the flu I'll
just stay in bed all day
exactly and what's really scary and has
my brett my friend bring me some soup
and but that's but i don't blame people
for that and then their friend has it
right and then the friend leaves not
knowing oh they just had the flu I
brought him soup and 20 20 percent gets
severe cases in that means
hospitalization 20 percent 20 percent
matter in that yeah so moat the mostly
people who have died have been older
people with pre-existing conditions okay
but younger people have died too like
that is freaky no like a like some
people in their 30s like that's like
this supposed to be healthy though yeah
like the one guy was a doctor that's
like the big main story of the doctor
like a 30 year old doctor he was like in
his 30s right how old is he
he was 34 34 34 that's like our age but
you know you'll be good we we we we you
know our job is based in an isolated
basement which we never have to leave so
we're gonna lock ourselves inside play
Magic the Gathering and never go out and
then and I just got back from flying to
my other spot running around in your car
here running around in the dirt
yeah that's literally getting all dirty
even with rained a little bit too so
it's super muddy there's a lot of fun so
look I'll wrap the we can we can wrap
this one up and well I'll just say
because I know I say it a lot but I mean
with the utmost sincerity I'm
you know I did a promo from from prepare
with IMCOM earlier on my other channel
I'm showing now just because five week
delay a hundred times demand I think is
news in and of itself even if this isn't
gonna be the worst thing in the world
you can see how it'll affect supply
chains that means your favorite you know
you like that fancy toasted raviolis you
get at your local store that's gone okay
well well what about some dry pasta
noodles in water well they left those
behind so that's what you'll get to eat
so take it to take it seriously right
yeah definitely and I guess we'll see
what happens Trump's head is on it I
think I think you know I think it's bad
and I think our reaction has been pretty
good we're not expecting the apocalypse
but you want to have a little bit of an
overreaction because an under reaction
would be worse right yeah that's true so
I'll leave it there and we'll jump over
some super chats but we do have another
story this one's even crazier Facebook
is censoring concern posts apparently
like ads that are yeah this is nuts yeah
this this shocked me so I'm gonna read
where did it I don't know actually I'm
I'm not surprised but it's it is like
they're that they're blocking
coronavirus oh dude I'm so not surprised
Facebook has been since aureus and going
on you're right you're right and then
we'll get into it we're gonna read the
super chance in the one to come back to
this next story where apparently
Facebook is banning ads that want to
create a sense of urgency around the
virus that's nuts
yeah government is doing it yeah the CDC
just came out and was like you guys need
to have a sense of urgency and now
Facebook's like nope ban like no no no
we banned the CDC from Facebook like all
right let's let's grab as many super
chests as we can and then we'll jump
over to the next segment Facebook
censorship in a time of crisis is is
freaky to me yeah of all times you want
to talk politics you annoy me yeah it's
actually happening Crona virus is
spreading all right why shouldn't there
be a sense of urgency let's grab these
super chats otherwise we'll keep so Liam
Stroud says how much do you think
smaller towns in the middle of nowhere
with relatively small population
low-to-mid thousands will be affected if
the coronavirus assume he meant spreads
that's what I was thinking and I bet I
don't think that those I think those
small towns aren't going to be as
affected no you're wrong Adam didn't you
just drive through a bunch of small
towns on your way from Phoenix so
saying I have a coronavirus I'm just
saying if you did oh if I did you work
hopping earlier I'm kidding no no listen
listen was I smaller towns still need to
get their supplies from other places
that's true yeah so self-sufficient
small farm towns probably okay well I
mean I drove past hundreds and hundreds
of truckers yeah yep and those truckers
are driving nine days from yeah exactly
so they they pick up some stuff throw it
on the truck shake the hand of the dude
that they've known for 30 years who J
got it from something else spreads yep
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you